[Music]
there is no day
to see how much it will help you in
california in which don harris will have
big spanish the referent dominique in the
garden get happy the life for a dream
guardes big spanish I am the complete boasts
of the children in going from is
It's better that you immerse yourself with the prat, you hear,
they don't have it now. I speak Spanish very
perfectly
in this regard, it would be
dyn
this river
[Music]
which one do you want to do which well, with a
studio from Madrid they mess with Manny Pérez,
little easy, easy,
as they say to yes, no
[Music]
ok
is of the water
for our intelligent citizens I
did not understand
this back then and not if you do like the ine
[Laughter]
I am intelligent grace grace like
every time another shore this knows that it
is for that for  this for kristen art
in the item in a brief insight
I ask her about something and she tells me 50
thousand I don't understand it
gray but this is green sale window
office kitchen camera
we are more the same than different 20
minutes
[Music]
88 min 88 songs my sincere
888,888 pesos but I don't know what he's
saying he can give me he's saying
that he's a stripper who dances to this
song and it's the most famous song he
's doing that's the universe he
understands  I understand what
10 looks at it is giving me heat we did not make it
more difficult than times the feeling
I would never have called in the head of
all pod after none the mission
pieces bomb in wine and I can't
wait where it goes I think when he
talks to me  Estela forgets that I don't speak
that language, she
doesn't know what's happening
[Music]
he doesn't know that he can't do it
because women are more intelligent
than men so that he knows that you're done for
a minute
[Music]
explain to me
[Laughs]
[Music]